hallo leute willkommen bei einer neuen
episode von kari antwortete
beziehungsweise kari und janosch
antworten unser heutiges thema ist nur
ein einziges janosch lies doch mal bitte
die kommentare von dieser woche vor
das erste kommentar von die deutschen
sind die dümmsten bunch of limbs rommel
ist assassin's creed and evil in der
inside
titel die heftige back to you can front
sind sind sie smoker linke fette dritte
heft ist fertig und wir haben ein
publikum jetzt und us palermo languages
autos
jetzt fragt ihr euch natürlich warum wir
schon wieder diese hass kommentare
vorlesen und wahrscheinlich denken
einige von euch
nein bitte nicht schon wieder hats
kommentare wir wissen dass euch das auf
den keks geht
allerdings ist es so dass wir diese
woche so viele von dieser arten von
kommentaren bekommen haben
das ist eine sehr grosse masse ist und
wir wollen einfach darüber reden denn
offenbar gibt es ein problem oder viele
leute haben ein problem und das sind
nicht wenige
denn wir haben diese woche ein video
hochgeladen
das über 30% discs und negative
kommentare bekommen hat und deswegen
wollen wir uns natürlich auch damit
auseinandersetzen warum haben wir dieses
video gepostet das video war gar kein
easy gemen video sondern es war ein
video dass wir zusätzlich gepostet haben
zu unseren normalen videos es ging um
eine promo-aktion für eine plattform die
bei der integration vor allem von
geflüchteten in deutschland helfen soll
das haben wir zusammen mit unseren
freunden abdul und aller von gls channel
gemacht die hier auch kennt um dieses
video hat sehr viele schlechte
kommentare bekommen erst mal warum
posten wir das überhaupt auf unserem
natürlich ist das kein deutsch lernen
video aber bei unseren kommentar bei
unserem kanal geht es ja nicht nur um
die reine sprache sondern eben auch um
die deutsche kultur und um unser land
und irgendwie auch um das kulturelle
zusammenleben ihr wisst wir haben immer
viele menschen aus unterschiedlichen
kulturen auch in unseren videos
wir treffen euch in der stadt für
treffen euch in anderen ländern
wir machen zusammen mit euch videos und
es ist so wenn wir ein video mit einem
italiener machen oder mit einem
amerikaner oder mit einem brasilianer
dann gibt es diese kommentare nicht wenn
wir allerdings ein video zu mit muslimen
machen gibt es plötzlich diese hass
kommentare und das finden wir ganz
schrecklich weil es ist offenbar ein
problem was leute mit muslimen haben und
nicht mit irgendwelchen anderen ländern
und deswegen möchten wir heute mit euch
darüber sprechen wenn ihr uns nach eurer
unserer persönlichen meinung fragt also
viele werfen uns ja vor dass wir blind
sind oder dass die deutschen so
brainwash sind und keine probleme sehen
und sie wollen immer nur alles gut sehen
und sie
sie sagen uns dass wir sachen ausblenden
oder dass wir dumm sind und das ist
nicht so
wenn ihr wissen wollt unsere persönliche
meinung wenn ihr uns fragt gibt es ein
problem mit dem islam gibt es ein
problem dass muslime haben dann sagen
wir natürlich gibt es ein problem eine
religion die tausende von menschen dazu
benutzen um gewalt auszuüben und
terrorismus aus sieben menschen zu
unterdrücken
die hat natürlich ein problem das kann
man ja gar nicht anders beschreiben und
es wäre naiv zu sagen es gibt keine
probleme natürlich gibt es probleme aber
was wir übersehen wenn wir jetzt dafür
pauschal alle alle muslime
verantwortlich machen ist eben genau das
dass es eine pauschalisierung ist ich
kann nicht sagen
es gibt probleme und dann sagen eine
milliarde menschen sind dafür
verantwortlich wenn wir uns die menschen
angucken die so unterschiedlich sind
auch so vielen unterschiedlichen ländern
kommen dann müssen wir feststellen dass
95 prozent der muslime gar nichts zu tun
haben mit den terrorismus diesen nicht
unterstützen und einfach nur in frieden
leben wollen und wenn wir dann noch
sehen dass es unter diesen 95 prozent
ganz ganz ganz viele gibt die sich sogar
aktiv dagegen einsetzen die etwas
verändern wollen in ihren ländern die
für demokratie kämpfen für frauenrechte
kämpfen die gegen terrorismus kämpfen
dann ist das eine sache die wir auch
beachten müssen und unsere freunde
abdulin aller sind genau solche menschen
die eben nicht nur sagen auch alles ist
super wir sind jetzt in deutschland
super wir haben keine probleme sondern
sie sind genau zwei von denen die dafür
kämpfen etwas zu verändern
die darüber sprechen was in ihren
ländern passiert die auch ihre mitbürger
aufrufen etwas zu verändern die beiden
sind zum beispiel welche die mitgeholfen
haben in deutschland einen terroristen
zu fassen
das sind zwei leute die sich dafür
einsetzen dass frauen gleichberechtigt
werden was in vielen muslimischen
ländern noch nicht der fall ist
und jetzt kommt also ihr die solche
kommentare schreibt und ihr beschimpft
diese menschen die sich dagegen
einsetzen
das problem ist nicht dass man keine
angst haben soll oder dass man einfach
alles verein soll dass es eben nicht das
problem
das problem ist aber oder die frage viel
besser ist wie finden wir eine lösung
und wenn wir feststellen dass es auf der
welt probleme gibt dann sollten wir auch
darüber nachdenken wie wir eine lösung
finden und einfach menschen pauschal
beschimpften und es recht diese menschen
die sich schon für eine lösung einsetzen
ist eben der falsche weg und wir sehen
das auch und deswegen sprechen wir da
auch heute drüber
es ist es ist natürlich nicht der
hauptteil unserer videos aber in manchen
wenigen videos beschäftigen wir uns auch
mit dem thema integration mit dem thema
muslime
deutschland weil es eben ein teil von
deutschland ist ist es ja nicht so dass
wir darüber nicht sprechen in
deutschland oder dass sie einfach
schweigen und sagen auch alles ist super
jetzt haben wir hier eine million neue
menschen und alles geht gut nein das ist
es nicht sondern wir setzen uns eben
aktiv dafür ein dass diese integration
gelingt unter anderem mit diesem projekt
fahrt auf was wir unterstützen und ja
wenn ihr selber eine lösung volt und
wenn ihr dabei mithelfen wollte dass wir
in diesen momenten diesem land gut mit
unseren mitmenschen klar kommen dann
solltet ihr uns auch unterstützen und
nicht einfach nur schreiben ihr seitdem
ihr seid scheiße ihr seid linke
oder was wir da alles gelesen haben das
waren nur 10 kommentare von vielen was
ich selber sein kann aus meiner
erfahrung als deutsche wir deutschen
haben ja auch trance probleme gehabt in
unserem land ich bin aufgewachsen in
einem land das eigentlich die größte
verbrechen der welt begangen hat und
jetzt sagen manche leute ach ja ja ja
seid so immer so gut und ihr wollt alles
wieder gut machen aber es geht gar nicht
darum etwas gut zu machen sondern es
geht eigentlich darum was wir daraus
gelernt haben ich selber kennen das wir
fahren sind in sehr viele länder
gefahren
in unserem leben und es gibt so viele
orte auf der welt wo die leute nichts
anderes über deutschland wissen als die
nazi geschichte und wie oft ist es mir
schon passiert das leicht sagen du bist
deutsche du bist ein nazi oder heil
hitler oder lebt adolf hitler eigentlich
noch das sind die witze mit denen sich
deutsche beschäftigen die um die welt
reisen
denn das ist ein bild was uns immer noch
prägt und ich kann als deutschland ich
heutzutage sagen auch mit den nazis habe
ich nichts mehr zu tun
ihr seid alle dummen dass es mir
scheißegal ich beschäftige mich
natürlich mit meiner geschichte und so
beschäftigen sich auch viele viele viele
muslime mit den problemen die andere
muslime in ihrem namen verursachen
obwohl sie gar nichts damit zu tun haben
jetzt
muss ich gucken was ich noch dazu sagen
wollte ich wollte einfach sagen
helft uns mit an einer lösung zu
arbeiten wir haben probleme in der welt
wir haben extrem viele probleme wir
haben kriege wir haben terrorismus wir
haben armut
wir haben viele probleme die dadurch
entstehen durch den terrorismus und ein
problem davon ist nämlich pass und
unverständnis und ihr solltet nicht dazu
beitragen dass sich diese sachen
verschärfen sondern uns mithelfen dass
die welt ein kleines stückchen besser
wird und wenn ihr angst habt vor
muslimen
dann kann ich nur sagen ich verstehe
euch zumindest ein bisschen weil wenn
ihr keine muslime kennt so wie ich ein
viele muslimische freunde habe dann hat
man natürlich vielleicht manchmal das
gefühl oh nein alles ist schlecht aber
ich kann euch nur sagen es ist nicht
alles schlecht und was wir tun sollte
und auch mist ist informiert euch glaubt
nicht einfach alles was da draußen steht
glaubt nicht wenn euch jemand sagt dass
alle muslime schlecht sind glaubt das
nicht einfach wenn euch jemand sagt das
einfach alle muslime kriminell sonst
glaubt das nicht es gibt viele fakten
und es gibt viele informationen gehen
sollte und vor allem solltet ihr euch in
einem dialog einbringen und dann kann
man auch probleme ansprechen und dann
kann man auch hoffentlich zu einer
lösung beitragen janisch jetzt habe ich
hier meine meinung gesagt was sagst du
[Musik]
leute sollen sich informieren und leute
sollen sich darauf wir sind das dass sie
auch herz haben oder normal bleiben wir
sind in deutschland leute gekommen die
vor allem klicks nicht und die lösungen
sind schon da so wir werden es schaffen
und zwar alle probleme und die leute die
sind geschrei
die so laute sich beklagen verstehen die
situation nicht aber sie sind auch sie
sind
sie haben angst
viel zu große als sind
vielleicht linie
und das brauchen wir nicht
und vor allen dingen lassen sie in ruhe
mit euren kommentaren mit einem hass
kommentar wir machen videos für unsere
freunde
unsere freunde richten diese videos ok
also nochmal dazu ich weiß manche leute
werden wir nicht ändern und wir müssen
auch nicht auf jedem haus kommentar
eingehen aber da wir in der letzten
woche so viele bekommen haben wollten
wir heute mit euch über das thema
sprechen und dieser aufruf ist nicht nur
für diejenigen die so etwas geschrieben
haben sondern auch für die vielen vielen
leute die nicht sagen wir haben auch
viele positive kommentare bekommen aber
es gibt eben auch hunderte tausende
leute die sollen video gucken die
vielleicht selber angst haben oder keine
klare meinung und auch ihr sollt etwas
dazu sagen wenn ihr seht dass es so
viele negative reaktionen gibt dann seid
teil davon sei aktiver teil dieser
gesellschaft und informiert euch und
lasst euch nicht von diesen hassan
stecken denn dieser hass hat in
deutschland schon einmal zu einer der
grössten scheiße auf der welt geführt
und leider wissen wir deutsche und wisst
ihr auch was daraus passiert ist und wir
möchten nicht dass das wieder passiert
und dafür werden wir uns auch immer
aktiv einsetzen das hat nichts damit zu
tun dass wir lieber mit muslimen drehen
oder über muslime reden als über andere
nationen oder dass wir politik auf
unserem kanal machen wollen das ist
einfach teil von der deutschen
gesellschaft und teil des diskurses in
diesem land und deswegen wird das auch
immer ein kleiner teil auf unserem
easyjet kanal sein
seit uns nicht böse drum wir
beschäftigen uns ja auch mit anderen
themen
wir möchten uns eben mit allen themen
beschäftigen und wir möchten uns auch
mit allen gruppen beschäftigen und da
dieses thema gerade in deutschland
aktuell ist ist das natürlich auch ein
teil auf unserem kanal
wir möchten euch bitten seid nett seid
friedlich zueinander
sprecht probleme an den probleme sind da
und wenn wir sie verheimlichen
dann gibt es eben irgendwann solche hass
kommentare und gibt es solche
diskussionen
wir sollen aber das feld oder den
diskurs nicht von diesen leuten
bestimmen lassen die diese hass
kommentare aussprechen sondern wir
sollen alle aktiv daran mitarbeiten
bitte schickt uns eure kommentare sagt
uns was ihr denkt bleibt dabei
freundlich und in der nächsten woche
werden wir wieder all die guten und
netten und freundlichen kommentare
beantworten und all die fragen zur
deutschen sprache und kultur
daher schickt uns bitte jetzt eure
fragen und in der nächsten woche
beantworten die bilanz jannis sagt süß
an die welt
[Musik]
und